Oh hello i know right
Welcome back everyone big
surprise marvel dropped a brand new deadpool 3
teaser with a bunch of jokes so we'll
break it all down not to be forgotten like
they just dropped a bunch of trailers obviously
deadpool would not want you to forget about him
there was also a deadpool deleted scene from
dr strange 2 that was meant to be an alternate
post-credits scene so i'll talk about that during
the video too if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we also
have obi-wan kenobi episodes coming next week i'll
be doing videos for all them as well but marvel
just had themselves a couple big weeks they just
released doctor strange two in theaters the moon
knight finale they've released a bunch of teasers
and trailers for the upcoming shows like she-hulk
the nick fury secret invasion series and some of
the stuff that's a little further off i've already
done videos for all those things like i did all
the moon knight episode videos i did a bunch of
videos for doctor strange too the she-hulk trailer
so i'll put those links in the description below
but just this morning as i'm posting this video
like a day after all the trailers and everything
dropped not to be forgotten deadpool 3 released a
new teaser on their account with a bunch of jokes
about the movie that they're currently working on
the text of the post reads deadpool 3 update we've
nailed down brand integrations story character
and script next with a big teaser image of a
scene with peter who you last saw in deadpool 2
in a scene with a bunch of very ryan reynolds
deadpool specific jokes about product integration
it's another one of those zoom in hands kind of
easter egg post that ryan reynolds has done for
deadpool 3 the past couple of years every once in
a while the first big joke here obviously they're
just being funny about the progress of deadpool
3. they've actually been writing that movie for
the past couple years they hired the writers
for that movie back in 2020 so they actually
do have a story it's just that they won't start
actually filming the movie for a little while
most of you probably been able to spot some of
the more obvious easter eggs in this peter scene
here some of them are more obvious than others
there's meant to be a ton of funny easter eggs and
references with brand integrations for deadpool
3 that they've added to this specific scene
that's what they're talking about in the post
when they say that they've figured out all the
brain integrations for the movie for those
of you that aren't really familiar with the
way the big tentpole movies like this are made
or really all movies in general you could say
is that because they cost so much money to make
even the smaller movies one of the ways that
they offset the cost is by working in a lot
of brand integrations just having brands pay
millions and millions of dollars to have
their products used in movies in some way
like that's the reason why marvel
always use audi cars for a bunch
of the marvel movies particularly the iron
man movies but a lot of the other movies too
you see things like that in pretty much every big
movie like why is that logo so big like why are
they drinking that particular beer oh it's because
that brand paid millions of dollars to the movie
but because this is deadpool 3 and ryan reynolds
himself actually owns or owned a bunch of actual
brands in real life they turned all of those into
deadpool 3 jokes like you acknowledge you're a
character in a movie but you also make fun of
that movie while you're in it they kind of did
that during doctor strange 2 with bruce campbell's
character in the second post credit scene which
i'll talk about when i talk about the deadpool
deleted scene from that movie breaking the fourth
wall just to make fun of yourself and make fun of
your own movie but this scene is basically making
a bunch of real-life ryan reynolds deadpool jokes
like you see ryan reynolds always posting videos
of himself on his channels hawking products and
services for things that he himself owns like why
is he doing so many advertisements oh he owns
these brands he's trying to earn money for the
brands that he owns he's trying to earn more money
himself the deadpool and korg mcu video that they
posted was actually done as an ad for the free guy
movie but the reason why they let ryan reynolds
use the deadpool character to do that and make
all those marvel references is because free guy
was a fox film in disney bought fox so technically
disney owns everything that's happening in this
scene here they own all the marvel stuff they
own all the fox stuff too but he did say that
he had to get special permission from marvel to
be able to film this using his deadpool character
well hello there and what's up reaction faction
it's deadpool don't forget to smash that subscribe
button and follow me on patreon most of you
also remember peter from deadpool 2. but if
you look around this scene with him you see a ton
of products or shout outs to different businesses
products and organizations that ryan
reynolds either owned or was part of
so big time zoom in enhanced one of the most
obvious ones here is the aviation gin on the table
he was owner or part owner of that brand he posted
so many aviation gin videos the past couple years
he even posted a funny wolverine vs deadpool one
with him and hugh jackman feuding with each other
ryan reynolds is a complete and total the gin's
pretty great though i'll have to try it someday
sorry man i didn't think the truce was actually
real i love the way he just pours that on the
table like just telling ryan reynolds that he
sucks in real life really though they're like
best friends they do this all the time where
they just make fun of each other and the ads
for each of their different products or services
or whatever it is they're promoting for each other
there's a bunch of budweiser bottles and cans a
can for sapporo beer a cooler for monster energy
drink now he doesn't own any of those brands
like budweiser's sapporo or monster himself
but like i said movies usually pay millions of
dollars to have their logos show up in films
zooming in hands on peter's jacket the jacket he's
wearing is for mint mobile that's a mobile service
company that ryan reynolds himself owns he posts
a bunch of videos for that especially recently
zoom in enhanced in the background here
there's a maximum effort company logo
so maximum effort obviously a deadpool
phrase that he uses in the comics and
they've done in the movies a couple times
has appeared several times in the films
but in real life when the first deadpool movie
came out ryan reynolds himself created his own
production company in real life and called it
maximum effort as a reference to the actual
character in the film he used that to help produce
the movie he used that during deadpool 2. he used
to produce pretty much all the movies that he's
involved in i'm assuming that he had to get
special permission from marvel to call his company
maximum effort just because they had a trademark
on the deadpool character but he also turned that
maximum effort company into a digital advertising
agency like this is a big joke about putting
ads in movies in real life his maximum effort
company actually helps regular brands and networks
film their own ads like you probably see a bunch
of ryan reynolds filmed as even if ryan reynolds
himself doesn't appear in them like a couple years
ago there was this pelton ad with a lady that
was really funny just because people dragged it
so much it was a really bad ad so right after that
ryan reynolds like turned on a dime and used her
in a parody style ad on that for his aviation
gin brand just recently he did the same thing
for peleton shooting another parody ad for them
featuring mr big from sex and the city right
after his character had died in that series using
a pelletin if you look right next to the maximum
effort logo on this board here there's a poster
for wrexham afc which is a british football club
that ryan reynolds owns in real life with rob
from always sunny they post some ads for that
then if you zoom in enhance on the upper
left hand side here there's a video for mntn
software with this figure playing on the tv that's
actually advertising software that ryan reynolds
developed himself using his maximum effort company
in real life to help agencies who actually buy and
place ads for companies do it better the banner
underneath it with the gei percentage symbol here
is also a technical advertising term and as funny
as it is to see him hawking so many products and
services for companies that he started in his
own movie deadpool 3 in real life he actually
just sold a controlling interest for some of these
businesses for hundreds of millions of dollars so
the joke's on us because he just made several dump
trucks of money doing all this different stuff
and that's on top of the money that he earns being
a huge movie star like he earned robert downey jr
level money on deadpool 2 and he'll earn even more
on deadpool 3. if there any other really obscure
easter eggs in the background here that you think
you spotted just write them below in the comments
the place where peter is standing inside
this room here is meant to be the same
office that you saw during deadpool 2 where
they were recruiting the x-force team members
the joke is that the office is meant to be like
in the back office of the bar where weasel worked
where they were using to manage all the assassin
jobs for everyone that deadpool was working with
the name of that bar was sister margaret's school
for wayward girls they had a rob lightfelt cameo
scene in the first movie because he was one
of the creators of deadpool in the comics
the reason in the movie why he was called a
deadpool in the first place is because the
contest that they all played at that bar was to
see which one of them would die during a hit job
literally calling it the deadpool talking about
that deadpool deleted scene in doctor strange
too multiverse of madness because the writer did
say they pretty much talked about every single
character you could imagine under the sun being in
that movie at one point i believe the scene with
deadpool was meant to be one of the post-credits
scenes like in the theatrical cut they had the
scene of doctor strange meeting clia from the
dark dimension going with her to stop the next
incursion it's meant to be a big secret wars
teaser there's a whole bunch of easter eggs in
here so i did a much bigger video i'll post a link
in the description if you want to learn more about
what's going on with ad the second post-credit
scene was the bruce campbell scene just meant
to be like a funny joke about his papa's pizza
balls character after doctor strange's spell had
worn off with him breaking the fourth wall kind of
like deadpool there were a bunch of other easter
eggs in that that i talk about in that separate
post-credits scene video you can watch that if
you want to learn about those specifically but i
think originally what they had intended is that
the deadpool post-credits scene would have been
that funny second post-credit scene instead of
bruce campbell and he would have been breaking the
fourth wall just telling some deadpool style jokes
about the movie itself like commenting about
finally being in the mcu or making jokes about
the mcu because he just did that deadpool and
korg scene with mcu korg joking about making it
into the mcu any tips on uh getting into the mcu
there cork kevin feige did confirm that deadpool
3 would be an mcu movie it would be rated r but
because of that they kind of be treating the film
like it was his own separate thing even though it
was meant to be an mcu film i've done a bunch of
videos for all the other deadpool 3 teasers in the
deadpool mcu videos you can click here to watch
that deadpool and korg video and click here for
my brand new she-hulk trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!